ROB EASTAWAY: "Jurassic Park,"
we've all seen the film, but
very few people have read
the book, including me.
I've not actually read the book,
but I have looked at the
pictures because there's
something in there that is
just kind of really weird, a
little pattern, a beautiful
pattern that's very
little known.
So I just wanted to
share it with you.
So we're going to get
to it just by--
I've just got a random
piece of paper here.
It happens to be brown.
We're just going to fold this
bit of paper in half.
So I fold it like this, crease
it, and you've kind of got a
seagull there.
And if it forms a
V, of course.
I mean, nothing surprising
so far.
I'm going to be consistent
here.
So I'm folding that which is
your left over right, and I'm
going to do it again.
So fold it again, left over
right, and crease it.
And if I sort of pull it apart
now, OK, so we've got, reading
left to right, can you see
there's a sort of peak, then
there's a valley, then
there's a valley.
So we'll call this peak,
valley, valley, OK?
Or and remember this for later,
if I sort of close it
up a bit, it's a sauce
spoon, OK?
So I fold it over once,
and I fold it twice,
and I fold over again.
Now, can you predict what the
pattern is going to be of
valleys and peaks?
Now, you'd probably think that
something as repetitive as
this is going to be some really
obvious pattern, and
it's either going to alternate,
maybe valley-peak,
valley-peak.
Or you might think--
I to know-- it's going
to create a little--
obvious little zigzaggy
kind of pattern.
But that's not the case.
If I pull it out, it goes
peak-peak; valley-valley;
peak; valley-valley.
So what's the pattern here?
And indeed, can you predict
what's going to happen when I
fold it for a fourth time?
So we do one, and two, and
three, and fold it a fourth
time, and unfurl it.
Well, it's kind of good to try
and predict before you see it,
but here we go.
And now we've got peak-peak;
valley; peak-peak;
valley-valley-valley; peak-peak;
valley-valley;
peak; valley-valley.
It's kind of--
if not random, it's certainly
not a really
obvious and easy pattern.
And if just start closing this
up, and you turn these into
right angles, you can see that
what's emerging is something--
well, something that's clearly
not trivial, but it's
certainly not clear
what's going on.
And this is where we turn
to the book, OK?
Could you get yourself your nice
cheap copy or brand new
copy of "Jurassic Park,"
and you turn to
page whatever it is.
And you have this page which
says "first iteration," and
you've got this pattern.
So this is actually what you get
when you fold our strip of
paper four times.
So if you call a fold an
iteration, really you should
be calling this the
fourth iteration.
I don't know why it's
the first iteration
in here, but anyway.
The second question, of course,
is what is it doing in
"Jurassic Park?" And there's a
little cryptic reference at
the bottom of the page by
Ian Malcolm who's the
mathematician who features
in this story.
"At the earliest drawings of the
fractal curve, few clues
to the underlying mathematical
structure will be seen."
So he talked about a fractal.
So this is going to turn into
a fractal of some kind.
Can you picture what that
fractal will be?
I certainly can't, not without
having seen it first.
If we keep folding our paper,
which we're not going to do
because there's a limit to how
many times even with a long
strip of paper you
can fold it.
Another fold, what's called
a second iteration here,
produces this pattern,
which is--
I guess that what's kind of
interesting is, without
crossing over itself, it joins
and forms this little block,
this little rectangle and
another square there.
I think the reason why there are
fractals appearing in here
is that there's a sort
of theme about the
unpredictability of systems and
chaos, and the fact that
we've set up Jurassic Park, and
all these creatures are
going to behave in
a certain way.
And here's this doom-monger
saying it could all go
horribly wrong because what we
think is predictable could
turn out to be chaotic
and so on.
So that's the metaphor, I think,
that's being used.
So if I keep folding
the paper, I
get the third iteration.
It's getting a bit more
involved, but it's still hard
to see any pattern emerging
from this.
And we go quite a lot of pages
further before we get to
what's called the fourth
iteration.
Actually, there's been a few
more folds here, so the
numbers at the top are kind
of going out the window.
But now we've got this big block
just from folding the
paper right over left,
and we zip ahead
to the fifth iteration.
Well, now you've got these kind
of blocks appearing, and
they're a bit like lizards.
I don't think that's a
deliberate reference to
Jurassic Park or anything, but
there's some things which are
almost animal-like
about this thing.
And you keep going to what's
called the sixth iteration.
There are lots--
way more than you can
fold a bit of paper.
You get this rather stunning
pattern emerging.
And in fact, what you'll find
is that each of these, the
main shape in the center, has
been then rotated and rotated.
And typically, they're being
rotated by 45 degrees, and the
dimensions are being reduced
by the square
root of 2 each time.
Why folding a piece of paper
could lead to something as
stunning as this is just--
you know, it's mind blowing.
We've all seen fractals.
There's lots of fractals
that are famous.
This one, which is so easy
to produce, is actually
remarkably little known despite
featuring in "Jurassic
Park."
And we go all the way to the
end, an infinite number of
folds of paper.
We get what's called here the
seventh iteration, this
beautiful solid block.
And even more stunning is the
fact you can picture sticking
another of these curves in.
They would sort of fit together
like jigsaw pieces.
You can see another dragon
curve outlined here.
So if you imagine you've got a
black one and a blue one and a
yellow one, you could actually
stick them together to make a
really cool kitchen
floor tiling.
It would be a bit hard to do.
But to produce something like
this, I don't think anyone
would predict that.
BRADY HARAN: That's
pretty cool.
ROB EASTAWAY: Mm.
I love it.
And I love the fact that the
whole world knows about
fractals, but whenever I show
a group of people the dragon
curve, they say I've never
seen this before.
And who would have thought
that you could
get to it so simply.
[DINOSAUR ROARS]
ROB EASTAWAY: I think
he likes it.
BRADY HARAN: If there are many
sides, then the angles become
too shallow so that the
next one would only
have a little bit.
I'm going to put in another
polygon out here and match
that one there.
I'd end up with only a little
sliver under there.